[Music]
we've been brainwashed into thinking by
Hollywood that a starship has to be huge
and gigantic the size of the enterprise
however the laws of physics make
possible sending postage stamp-sized
chips to the nearby stars so think of a
chip
perhaps this big on a parachute and have
thousands of them sent into outer space
energized by perhaps 800 megawatts of
laser power by shooting this gigantic
bank of laser energy into outer space by
energizing all these mini parachutes you
could then begin to accelerate them to
about 20% the speed of light this is
with doable technology today it's just a
question of engineering it's a question
of political will and economics but
there's no physics there's no law of
physics preventing you from shooting
these chips to 20% the speed of light
that means Proxima Centauri part of the
Alpha Centauri triple star system could
be within the range of such a device now
think about that that means that within
20 years after 20 years of launch we
might be able to have a the first
starship go to a nearby planet and it
turns out that Proxima Proxima Centauri
B is an earth-like planet that circles
around the closest star to the planet
Earth what a coincidence so what means
that we've already staked out our first
destination for visitation by an
interstellar starship and that is
Proxima Centauri B a planet that goes
around one of the stars in the triple
star system and so this could be the
first of many different kinds of
starship designs in my book the future
of humanity I go through many of the
possible design including fusion rockets
ramjet fusion rockets including
antimatter rockets some of these Rockets
of course they're technologies won't be
available to the next 100 years but
remember we're talking about the future
of humanity and
future of humanity I think could be in
outer space
[Music]
you